sup guys I'm Jenny Lorenzo and I was
born and raised in Miami Florida
technically born in Hialeah
and raised in Westchester and I'm not
talking about New York today's challenge
is that I need to figure out who's the
true Miamian in the group I've curated a
pretty badass list of questions so I'm
here I'm hosting a little Miami Pachanga
you know to get to know everybody and
see who's really really really like
literally from Miami
alright let's get the party started have
everybody come in so I can meet them
welcome to the patch on can't wait to
find out who the imposters are and who
the one 305 til I die is gonna start
with you mr. bartender how's it going my
name is Matt I want to ask you some
questions right off the bat what's up DC
has panda statues West Hollywood has the
electric guitar statues what public art
statue series is found scattered around
Little Havana number one guffy acetyl
cups number two roosters mm-hmm number
three flamingos or number four dominoes
number two roosters laverna you got it
right horse you got it right sir match
number two hmm what was the nickname
Hispanic Miamians gave to the farm store
chain of drive-thru markets and why it's
notorious column yeah even the white
people in Miami knows right of course
which is me the flow riders which is of
course reference to the musical artist
next question who is Florida know who is
the pimp with the limp we're talking
about the colonel himself Colonel
Sanders from KFC he's the captain limp
so for you but we got in one right
there's one bright roosters baby
it was lovely meeting you cockadoodledoo
to you cuckoo and I'll see you later
good goodbye
you know me dear well I'm a meat that
believe young women can tattoo outfit oh
good work you just gracias okay so you
ready to answer some question yes here
we go car accident remember after 911
for one one one
or what it's been a while since I've
been in the car accident what happens in
you're in a car accident get hit and
what happens if you get hit you die you
are close so I'm gonna give you a half
point okay
cool Coco everybody knows the miami area
code is 305 we'll have to think pitbull
for that but every Miamian also knows
the Broward area code what is it like
I'm a little bit busy I'm more South
Beach okay as you know Miami is heavily
Cuban very make sense she was like right
there so well good thing you mentioned
that because the question is how many
miles to Cuba is it from Key West I give
my arm span is like this like 400 miles
not quite
ask one more name at least three Miami
Dade College campus I haven't lived in
Florida since I was like 16 so okay so
where were you raised I was right in
Miami like I went to southwestern high
school okay and I was an athlete I
wasn't home alive okay do those
competing okay cool well thank you for
answering my question hey how are you
doing good how are you
come on oh nice to meet Jenny right yes
John so I'm gonna find out if you
actually spent some time in what I call
Cuba the sequel there's this really
popular fast food chain it's called boy
it'll be gone and everyone knows the
jingle so can you sing me the jingle you
want me to sing the jingle don't you
just sing the boy thought we got jingle
dig a little I good at it but I'll give
you that instrumentation not at all like
the real thing but bless your heart okay
so this is kind of like common knowledge
what hurricane was considered the most
devastating on record until Hurricane
Katrina it did almost equal damage say
what Katrina yes I'm not mistaken I just
don't remember the name of it I'll give
you a hint it's a male named hurricane
Albert Alberta no skid marks can you
imagine that
do you know how far Cuba is from Key
West
isn't it like 1200 around like 1200 1300
miles
oh dang see geography let's fry history
you tried okay this is some Miami
history okay I'm not that great at
speaking French but here we go
what French landmark is one of Miami's
most famous Cuban eateries named after
Moosa the Louvre champs elysées shut to
the Versailles and Moulin Rouge
this isn't me I want to say it's the
first one I don't know how to pronounce
it so you're gonna go with Moo say they
Louvre yeah so we'll go with that is all
you're Cuban you can't come after you in
a French history because it's a very
executive actually one here in LA wait a
second something Versailles that is a
hundred I mean you have to help you love
that you know you gave me the reference
of the LA landmark I've been out here a
little bit longer
why does it look like you're grading a
test right now you're gonna like just
because we take our culture very
seriously
hello hello hello nice to meet you
what's your name Jim a peddler energy
nylon Tony Battie
thank you are you Haitian yes ma'am ah
clue number one
cuz Miami has a lot of Haitians and that
we do Little Haiti
do you know Spanish little enough to
order food but you kind of know it a
little bit to get by of course
especially if I have to work retail like
me people will straight up only speak to
you in Spanish that's what my friend
well me then you work retail Miami you
could have caught me at the cotton on
talking wall you know oh I used to work
out my body works and daubenmire I am
NOT okay so that's awesome
Jimmy what is located at Tropical Park
aqua meadow and bird road journey my
heart me chorus song its how about
Santa's Santa's in santos' enchanted
forest
boom give me one hypothesis what it's
about okay so okay who is the pimp with
the lamp DJ lies that she calls you pimp
100% yes hit me with the tough ones all
right which of these places would you
not go to get fancy King some yellow
photos this Gaia Bayside or Biltmore I
don't know if you could tell but I
didn't have a kitchen yet I would say
since the Biltmore is kind of just like
a hotel
you probably wouldn't go there for the
photos but my second choice may be
Beavis kiya because that's where the
Venetian fool is you don't really want
kids splashing around in the background
but judging from your facial expression
it's the one that wasn't either of those
you're an actor aren't you God so you're
saying the answer is based on finally
answering bayside yeah well right yes
the school I actually did my Kissin
yellow photos at vizcaya and oh boy my
mom wanted it all think we're good what
done save the best for last
yeah you look gorgeous Electra thank you
so much
what's your name son - um I fell on my
[ __ ] that was French right maybe is that
the only other language you speak
English espanol a little bit French I'm
not assuming that you're Cuban what is
your background
Mexican cool I have Mexican friends in
Miami which local restaurant chain is
known for its ribs wings and collectible
green cups hi chica I used to be a
hostess I Flanagan's I used to host
there I think about it every once in a
while to make good food you finish this
jingle this is cheese jingle boy a
tropical huh
do you know it why don't you ask me
about the menu not the jingle I don't
give me the menu then would you have the
menu no I don't know I'll go back to
that another question that I asked
previously there is a chain of
drive-through farm stores the Hispanics
of Miami called it something else
based on the logo of the store no lavake
de Milo was obsessed with making me
drink milk and I'm not going to
tolerance thanks to a law in heaven you
are asking me the hardest ones okay well
this is gonna involve some cursing
people are always eating in Miami
what does eating mean use it in a
sentence
you got me there again it actually means
I'm not doing anything so in a sentence
it's like hey what are you doing nothing
so just eating what oh thank you thank
you you really tested me and grabbed
what's the point I want on my hands
there I know some of you might not even
know what that means but I'm very happy
to have met you all and interacted with
each and every one of you and I'm not
gonna lie when I first met you all I was
like each and every one of you could
easily be from South Florida so I was a
little torn between Reggie and Alma
obviously Reggie answered almost all the
questions right but you seemed like you
have spent some time in South Florida
but the winner is Reggie
my Haitian friend what was the answer
that gave it to you well it was the
Dolphin Mall thing him working at the
malls but that was once I knew all of
that I mean the ones that I did it where
are you all from
so I am actually from Florida and I'm
not from Miami I'm from Orlando
I love Orlando we women we always spend
time there did you go to the parks a lot
obviously I had my prom at Disney of
course yeah and then ten toes down oh my
gosh Warner Ray's got to Miami thing
Jenni I tried my best you did I'm
actually born in New York
my experience with Florida's visiting my
grandma in West Palm Beach
her parents live in West Palm Beach yeah
I'm a small town in California but I go
to Orlando every year like once a year
so that's about all I got from Florida
life I'm from Mexico but I lived in
Florida for like five years they to go
through the party scene to I just really
didn't ask any club in question you did
it you would have believed you would
have thought I wasn't from there from
how I went to the hipster clubs
this is a lot of fun and I hope you guys
learned something about Miami
so what city do you guys want to see
next say so in the comments below
[Music]